Joining me today is the milbank family
centers senior fellow at the Hoover
Institution at Stanford University,
a senior fellow at the Center for
European studies at Harvard,
where he also served as a professor of
history for 12 years as well as the
author of 14 books.
Neil Ferguson.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
It's exciting to be here.
How'd I do on the intro there?
I mean I was looking through your bio.
14 books.
There were 87 other things I could have
credited you for.
We've already done an interview here and
just the 15 minutes we've been sitting
here.
How was that all right.
I mean I could have just made it quicker
the better as my feeling about
introductions just to said he is Neil.
All right.
Here's Neil.
There's a ton we got to cover here and
we've already done half of it I think
without the cameras,
so let's just dive in immediately to the
culture war stuff because I can tell
you've been traveling a lot.
Half jet lags,
half wide awake,
but I can see that's really where your
head's at at the moment.
So let's talk some culture war stuff.
What do you feel is happening sort of in
the gestalt of the universe at the
moment?
We'll get started with the university
might be where we should begin since
I've spent a lot of my life in
universities.
You mentioned a couple of them,
the Stanford and Harvard.
I was at Oxford before that and um,
much of my life has been,
I think witnessing the gradual
homogenization of academic life,
especially in the field like history
when I became a historian back in the 19
eighties in Oxford.
And then in Cambridge it was generally
accepted that that could be conservative
historians and liberal historians and
socialist historians.
And then some oxys stories.
It was really quite a heterogeneous
community.
Oxbridge in those days.
And if you,
uh,
as I was attracted to the Conservatives
because they were more fun and it was a,
either they say more,
right,
but more fun.
But the fun was the initially attractive
thing when I first got to Oxford in the
early eighties.
It was clearly at the funniest people
where the riots,
uh,
the young Andrew Sullivan who was a year
ahead of me at Moreland,
so this was all great fun and it led to
intellectual,
uh,
insight because they turned out all
sorts of b writes,
the historians take Bob Conquest who was
then at the hoover institution,
one of the few historians who got the
Soviet Union right at the time who wrote
about Stalin's crimes not long after
they were put up a tracy.
I mean,
those were the heroes of my early years,
but in the course of my career,
what has happened has been that one
history department after another has
moved steadily and relentless me to the
monochrome left and it has become
steadily harder to be seen as a
conservative.
I say CNS because I,
I've never really felt that I'm a
conservative,
but I've often been described as one.
To be seen as a conservative historian
has become steadily harder and harder
and as a result,
but culture war to use your phrase in
the universities has been won by the
left.
There will really be soon a handful left
of conservatives at institutions like
Harvard and Stanford and Harvey
Mansfield will probably be the last one
at Harvard.
Uh,
and,
and that's,
uh,
to me deeply depressing,
deeply troubling.
Do you remember a moment when you saw
that shift occurring because you're
saying in the,
in the eighties,
mid eighties,
it was pretty diverse in terms of ideas.
Do you remember seeing something or did
you see markers that started that you
can start putting together the map of
where this thing was going to go?
I think the definition of defeats in the
culture war is that it's imperceptible,
uh,
your,
your aware of.
It's a little bit because in a typical
department,
each year somebody retires or dies,
but they're always replaced with
somebody working on that.
Say for the sake of argument,
gender history.
So you,
you'll colleague was a,
was lecturing on the history of the
Soviet Union.
Richard Pipes who was at Harvard and a
and just lately died,
one of the great historians of the
Bolshevik revolution.
You don't ever see someone like that
replaced with somebody like him that'll
always be replaced by somebody working
on gender history,
native American history that,
that process whereby there was no
replacement of conservative historians,
was a more or less annual events.
I got accustomed to being in a real
minority,
a minority of conservative historians.
I got accustomed to losing pretty much
every vote.
Being in the minority on every
committee.
It became a kind of you.
You've got to climatize to it.
And then one day suddenly hit you that
you were practically the last one left.
Uh,
and you know,
when I moved to Stanford,
the revelation was quite startling.
I was invited to come to the hoover
institution,
many hoover fellows who have
associations,
a joint appointments with Stanford
departments.
I had been pretty successful as a
teacher at Harvard.
My classes had been very large.
Uh,
the students gave me very powerful
evaluations.
Uh,
I kind of assumed that I would come to
Stanford and have some relationship with
the history department.
And then I was told,
oh,
no,
none at all.
Not even a courtesy appointment.
And it was clear at that moment that I
had become in the eyes of the Stanford
History Department,
but a pariah,
somebody who,
who simply couldn't be allowed in the
building because of my,
my conservative leanings.
Can you explain little bit more about
how the universities work like that,
that,
that could even happen?
They're going to,
they're going to bring you in,
you're,
you're a fellow there,
and that you're just going to be ignored
by the department that you're an expert
in.
It's quite insulting,
especially as you mentioned,
uh,
as I've published,
rather,
there are lots of Buddhists rather more
than,
than most of the department put
together.
And I think,
uh,
a department with falling enrollments
might have been expected to,
to want to have a me playing apart.
But what happened is,
and it's happened in most departments
and most universities inexorably the
left to Kovar and an implicit rule,
tacit rule was imposed.
That one does not hire,
right?
Leaning a historians know does one
higher.
They're graduate students.
So the two people who have been my
graduate students have found it
difficult,
uh,
to get hired.
So it's essentially a straightforward,
a process whereby the institution has
taken over one committee at a time and
the left has been good at that for the
better part of a century.
They've always.
How do you think they saw that?
How did they have the foresight to go?
All right,
we've got to take over the university's
first.
I think that on the right,
uh,
the previous generation of historians,
and this was also true of philosophers
and people working in other fields did
not fight very hard,
uh,
or effectively to promote their
successes in academic life.
You need to be mindful of the
succession.
The left was better at ensuring that
it's proteges got the appointments.
Ultimately academia is a committee's
game.
It's all about getting to be the chair
of the department to be in charge of the
committees.
If you control the process,
you control the selection,
you control the recruitment.
And I suppose I'm,
I'm such a naive person.
I kind of in my youth,
assumed we were in abroadly meritocratic
world in which if you were smart and
hardworking working then,
then good things would happen.
And it took me,
I was completely naive.
It took me a while to cottoned onto the
fact that in,
in reality,
in academic life,
as other walks of life,
patronage is everything and you can be
as talented as you like if you're not in
the right patronage network,
then you're done.
And I suppose it's been thinking about
these issues,
how do networks capture institutions
that,
that led me to write the most recent
book,
the square and the tower,
which is actually book number 15 to try
to think about how networks operate.
We,
we tend to talk casually about networks,
but I came to realize that in academic
life as another areas,
you need to understand quite exactly
quite precisely how networks operate.
To see how power is truly wielded.
We can all see the hierarchical
institutions that are,
where power is located.
Uh,
even universities are not as powerful
as,
as governments,
but the critical point is to understand
the disease often networks that capture
institutions,
the capture the hierarchies.
And that's what happened in academic
life.
And now I think pretty soon there just
won't be conservatives in university
departments.
More importantly than that,
nobody will be teaching subjects like
the history of the Soviet Union,
so no students will be taught about the
crimes of Lenin and Stalin and students
like the students I taught yesterday
will not hear from inability that the
was a religious motivation to the nine
slash 11 attacks.
I had a class at Stanford just the day
was allowed to sit in and teach somebody
else's class as a guest professor.
And it happened to be a discussion about
nine slash 11.
Uh,
and it became clear to me that the
students had never considered the
possibility that there was a religious
motivation,
uh,
to the nine slash 11 attacks and more or
less accepted the idea that they were
retaliation for the misdeeds of US
foreign policy in the Middle East,
what are called the Howard Zinn theory.
And since Howard Zinn's books are more
widely read in the United States than
anybody else's history books,
we therefore arrive at a situation in
which there will be nobody in any major
university saying,
actually,
Howard Zinn is completely wrong.
And this is not what nine slash 11 was
about.
So that's what I find depressing when I
say that the culture was kind of over in
the universities.
That's really what I mean.
Yeah.
So let's circle back because it does
bring us to your 15th book.
I stand corrected.
Um,
this,
this idea of networks because we were
talking right before we started that
there's something happening here with
this loose association of people that
has been coined the intellectual,
dark web.
And I said to you when you walked in,
are you part of the intellectual,
dark web as if you were going to give me
a secret handshake or a special card?
Or when I was asked about it,
I,
I denied all knowledge.
The assumption that it was secret and
then it turned out to be all over the
New York Times.
Yeah.
So you weren't,
you weren't photographed in the bushes
like the rest of us,
but I suspect that you secretly are in
the intellectual,
a dark web.
What?
I couldn't possibly reveal that because
it's secret.
But you said something interesting about
because of your level of academic,
sort of academic credit that you thought
perhaps that took you out of it,
but then Christina Hoff summers said
something interesting.
You go from there.
What
was it?
Emailed me and my wife Ayaan Hirsi Ali,
who's been on your show is much more
interesting than me,
is the greatest.
I mean we.
She must be tough for you because
millions of people love your work and
everything else,
but it's like ion is like transcendence.
She's one of the most enormous,
wonderful blessing in my life to be
married to somebody who's just way more
interesting than me that's not looking
to so that.
So we were both asked my Barry Weiss,
the intellectual dark web,
and I'd said,
look,
how can I really claim to be part of
that?
When I taught for 12 years at Harvard,
left of my own volition,
I'm here at Stanford,
can write newspaper columns and have
them published more or less where I want
it would.
It would be a little disingenuous to to
claim kinship with people like Bret
Weinstein who've been persecuted by the
academic left.
Now I've been attacked.
I've been criticized,
but I haven't really been driven
underground,
at least not at this point,
but Christina Summers said to me just
the other night,
no,
it's not about whether you've been
denied a platform or not.
Clearly,
almost all the people in the article
that Barry wrote of have plenty of
opportunities to make their views known.
It's about whether you are seen to speak
for people who feel that they have been
silenced,
who feel that their voices aren't heard
night.
That's quite a good definition of what
this is about,
but you're also right to,
to,
to see that it's a network.
As I was reading the article,
I was thinking how funny I know all
these people.
I'm the sole exception of Jordan
Peterson,
who I've never.
That um,
I,
I sent that's coming.
Yeah,
I hope so.
I look forward to it.
Um,
but I,
I,
I think it's a network of the most,
uh,
ideal sought.
It is a truly informal network of people
from right across the political spectrum
because nobody could call Bret Weinstein
of conservatives who have come together
spontaneously,
informally.
Nobody called it into being and said,
I'm forming the intellectual dark web.
Turn up on Monday at 5:00
PM.
Change as it change the second it's
name,
generally a network.
So if this is the right type of network,
right?
It's cool.
Kind of diverse group of people who had
all sorts of different motivations and
everything else.
Once it's sort of named,
does that change the way a network has
to operate?
Because I sent.
That's what the discussion is about
right now.
Although I'm not not.
I think fundamentally that the critical
thing is when something ceases to be
secret.
I tell the story of the Illuminati,
a network in the late 18th century in
Germany that sought to advance a radical
version of the enlightenment,
but covertly as a secret organization.
The intellectual dark web I sent me
seriously said was secrets until Barry
wrote that,
and now that it's out in the open,
what will happen is that it will grow
because people are Andrew Sullivan.
I was discussing with him to said,
hmm,
why am tiredness?
And of course the answer is,
but you should be really,
I mean anybody who,
who is engaged in critical thinking
about the whole range of ideas in our
society,
ranging from the political to the social
and cultural,
anybody who is in the debate and is
antagonistic to the dogmas of the left,
uh,
the political correctness,
the identity politics,
the spurious pursuit of so called social
justice.
If you are skeptical,
if you are thinking critically about the
dogmas of the left,
then you belong in the intellectual dark
web because you're the kind of person
who will at some point will be no
platformed,
who at some point will be taken down who
at some point will be the target of a
hit piece in the New York Times.
One of the characteristic features of
the intellectual dark whereby think is
that most members at one time or another
have fallen foul of the leftist thought
police and as soon as you've had that
experience,
it's happened to me a number of times
that is quite transformative.
Yeah.
I mean,
it literally changed my life.
It's the only reason you're sitting here
right now.
I was once one of them and and I suspect
that your experience was like mine.
You're kind of taken aback to be on the
receiving end of a social media mob.
You're kind of taken aback to be
attacked,
not for the substance of anything that
you've argued or written or said.
You're attacked for your reputation,
you're attacked for your alleged bad
faith,
and each time this has happened to me,
I've.
I've been a little stunned.
I was naive.
Not only was I a believer in
meritocracy,
I was also a believer that we were
engaged in a rational debate about the
past.
That's what historians do a and that one
made ones case presented the evidence
and then the other side did the same,
but I wrote a book,
a book about the British Empire.
Now what,
15 or so years ago,
an argument.
That argument of that book was that not
everything about the British empire was
bad.
Then there are benefits as well as costs
to imperialism and I never had a debate
about that argument.
I only ever was attacked by the left for
being an apologist of empire and
neocolonialist,
et Cetera.
Uh,
and so in that curious debate that,
that is central to the culture war you
never really are engaged with on the
ideas or the evidence it is always about
whether you have bad faith or not,
whether you are covertly,
yeah,
racist,
uh,
an Islamaphobe,
a homophobe that there's a long list of
things that you can be accused of,
but are the most popular ones.
Ones never really discussing the
arguments of the books.
One's always discussing the personality
of the author.
Yeah.
So this is just sort of simply put the
ideas verse people conversation.
Right?
So in a case of a van,
I mean to live through the things that
she has lived through between fgm and
her and her and her friend being
murdered and the whole thing to be
called the things that she's called.
I mean,
it flips,
you're very personhood on its head,
which is.
I mean it's,
it's so deeply twisted.
The episode that,
for me brought it into bold relief was
the brandeis a honorary degree fiasco
when I was invited by the president of
Brandeis and this was in 2017 to accept
an honorary degree and speak at
commencement.
And then,
uh,
was very publicly and humiliatingly
disinvited under pressure from an unholy
alliance as far as I could see of
leftists and Islamicists who sets out
online to smear her reputation with the
usual confection of selective quotation
and,
and misrepresentation.
And as often happens in these
situations,
the university authorities capitulate
without a fight,
uh,
to the left and,
and they do it publicly.
And that,
that for me was a,
that was a moment when I learned a lot
about what was going wrong in American
academic life and realize that it's the
combination of,
of aggressive activists on the left,
um,
and useful idiots in a university.
Bureaucracies.
So fold it.
Is it that they're useful idiots or is
it just,
is it just sort of blanket cowardice by
on part of some of the academics,
but really the,
the administrators and the upper brass
at all the schools.
And the fact that the donors,
although this is changing right now,
and as we're taping this today,
I know it's going to be out in a couple
of days,
um,
evergreen is now firing a whole bunch of
professors,
which is exactly whatever what all of us
predicted,
basically because the donors have just
had enough.
It's fascinating.
So it's hard to figure out where does it
come,
just coders.
Coders is the most powerful force in
human history,
no doubt.
And I'm constantly amazed at just how
much cowardice is out there.
Uh,
my wife's experience has shown me that
the,
the difficulty of getting people
publicly to support her work against
Islamic extremism is all about
cowardice,
fear of being in any way drawn into,
into the,
the real war,
the jihad,
facing the death threats that she has
repeatedly had to face.
But it's not just cowardice.
And there's a good deal of complicity.
Many university administrators are
themselves ideologically on the left and
feel that they have a mission to empower
the leftists in the student body.
Uh,
and this is,
I think,
a different thing from,
from covered this.
So yeah,
I think,
I think this is a fascinating moment in
time because donors,
alumni look at what is going on,
uh,
on university campuses as do people who
have not had the privilege of university
education who see it almost complete
madness and ask the question,
what the hell is going on here?
And I think the more that question gets
asked,
the better,
but we should not underestimate the
massive inertia in the system.
It is extremely hard.
Even if you're a university president,
you say,
right,
I'm going to clean house.
It's really hard to do because they're
all tenured.
I mean the faculty is tenured.
It's hard to get what happened
everywhere.
You know what I mean?
Like we don't find out,
you know,
in the northeast it's a little bit
better than,
you know,
just even geographically,
we just don't even see that.
Yes,
there are bastions of freedom.
I've heard University of Chicago or a
couple of places are a little bit
better,
but how do you think it actually spread
that way?
That it wasn't just here and there and
we'll this theory that universities are
always left wing,
but that's not true of,
for example,
if you had been in Germany in the 19
twenties,
uh,
the universities were bastions of
conservatism,
a,
an extreme and indeed extreme right wing
nationalism,
which is one reason that universities
very quickly went over to the Nazi
regime when Hitler came to power.
So it's,
there's no golden rule that says
universities have to be left wing.
Oxford and Cambridge in 18th century
were extraordinary reactionary,
a fundamentally religious institutions
and deeply Tori with a few exceptions in
the,
in the politics.
So there's no rule rule here.
Uh,
I think the best explanation I can offer
you is a process of generational capture
of education institutions dating from
the 19 sixties universities in let's
take the elite universities,
the Ivy League universities in the 19
fifties.
We're already seen as being liberal.
Um,
and if you were a kind of mccarthy
leaning Republican,
you already knew that Harvard was likely
full of fellow travelers and a covert
commies.
But the real shift I think came later.
I think it came with the antiwar
protests of the late sixties and early
seventies,
the more radical baby boomers who were
protesting in the campuses and 68 and
into the early seventies.
It grew up to become professors and
they're still around.
Uh,
and I think that generation which was
essentially formed at the time of the
antiwar protests,
successfully replicated itself.
They were very,
very good at replicating themselves by
creating graduate students in their own
image and then making sure that those
graduates,
students got jobs and,
and the right was nowhere.
So you were,
you were out there writing books,
doing research and figuring.
All right,
they're doing that.
And maybe in the long run on my heroes
at Oxford and Cambridge who,
who wrote great books and we're also
politically active people like norman
stone or Roger Scruton who did much of
the thinking that,
uh,
that accompanied that tourism in the 19
eighties.
What they did not do well was academic
politics.
They were poor it that,
uh,
they were poor at succession planning.
And that is,
I think,
the best explanation I can offer for the
fact that in nearly all universities in
North America and in Europe,
90 percent plus of faculty members are
Liberals or progressives,
if not outright Marxists.
Alright?
So with some of the historical context
of how this all happened,
I know you are enthused about this new
network idea and because it's come
around the right way,
do you think there's a gatekeeping
responsibility for whoever is involved
in this?
This seems to be one of the hot button
issues with this thing are who can be in
this?
Whatever it is,
what are the ideas that can not be on
the inside?
Uh,
I see it coming much more that we have
to watch out for ideas on the right than
on the left.
That seems to be the way it's being
framed,
at least from where I sit.
Um,
how would you do that in a,
in a proper network monitoring?
Two kinds of,
of,
of net was open access networks.
Let's take the example of facebook where
you can just join up an open a facebook
account.
You can even do it as a fake human
being,
and then there are the restricted access
networks,
uh,
extreme cases,
the secret societies of a,
of the 18th and 19th century don't
really have many analogs today because
it's hard to do anything secret in
barely exists any anymore in the age of,
of Wiki leaks.
So you have to decide whether to be an
open or closed or restricted access
network and the minute you are
restricted access network,
somebody is making the decisions about
who joins that then ends up being the,
the,
the membership committee and then you
were just a club.
Really.
I don't think that's an option in our
time.
I think an open access networks,
the only real way to go,
um,
and you must accept that if the,
uh,
if the intellectual dot webb is real,
that it's an open access network that,
that won't necessarily connect you to
ever really,
that you want to be connected to a may
connect you to people that you
positively don't want to be connected
to.
This has been a central problem I think
of uh,
being on the political right for a long
time.
I can remember in the 19 eighties when
people said to me,
well,
Neil,
you're a conservative,
and I would say,
well,
I'm actually not a member of the
Conservative Party.
I think of myself as a classical
liberal.
They would say,
oh,
but nevertheless,
when I look at all the things you say
you were a conservative,
and then I would think,
what does that mean?
That I have to have dinner with the
likes of,
I would think of various egregious
conservative members of parliament.
And it was as if you would be associated
with those people even if you never had
dinner with them.
And it's the same problem now except
that it's,
it's worse now because the way in which
the left seeks to discredit it.
Uh,
you,
Jordan Peterson and probably me as well.
Now that I'm on your show man,
I mean 15.
Look at the people who are connected to
these people who quote these people or
who read the books that there they are
over there,
but terrible alt right.
And you know,
when you say,
all right,
the audience is supposed to start booing
and hissing and you know,
Steve Bannon is supposed to appear in a
black robe with a sife.
You know,
I am deaf.
So I think that the problem is,
I think in escapable there will be a
constant effort on the left to say that,
uh,
the,
the intellectual dark web is just some
kind of a facade in front of a hideous
outright,
which is composed of remember racists,
Islamophobes,
homophobes,
and that will be the culture was next,
right?
I mean that is how it works.
We have a strange amount of gay people
and Muslim people and absolutely.
There you go.
Otherwise Brown people and every other
type of thing.
And the self,
the self hating phenomenon,
the left has long known how to say that
it is absolutely typical of the wicked,
right?
That they should have lured into that,
to the side,
a self hating.
And then you just fill in the blank.
Self hating Muslims self hating gays.
That's how this works.
Remember they lost all the arguments.
All they've got left is reputational
smearing man.
We got to fight in front of us.
Huh?
You know,
I,
I have lost sleep about this.
Not only because people threatened my
wife's life.
That's the real war that the war against
the Islamic extremists is.
No is no mere culture wards and actual
war.
I've also lost sleep about the media
culture war at the prospect of,
of the reputational attacks.
It's,
it's never pleasant to be attacked as I
was recently in effect for being a,
I guess a sexist,
racist or a racist sexist because I'd
organized a conference at which all the
speakers,
uh,
were white men because the women are
invited,
couldn't come back.
It was a private conference,
wasn't supposed to,
it wasn't.
He was kind of informal discussion about
how we could take the idea of applied
history and make history more relevant
to some of the debates that go on.
I think a lot of what has done in
academic history these days is not
really relevant to anything terribly
much,
but this event was a rather crudely
exposed in the New York Times and the
Washington Post,
uh,
the pictures of the speakers were
published as if the mugshots as it
appeared in the New York Times.
And the implication was that I must be a
terrible racist,
sexist,
or sexist racist for having organized
such a conference.
I did lose sleep about that.
Uh,
and I,
I think that part of the culture war is
really is really odious because it is,
it is calculated to discredit it,
uh,
the targeted individuals.
And it is,
it's bad faith on the part of the people
who launched those attacks.
So in my view,
what's happening with some of those
gated institutions when the newspapers
that used to be objective,
you know,
Barry wrote this piece in the New York
Times that I think was a pretty fair
piece.
It was even somewhat critical of me and
I'm not above criticism,
so I'm certainly okay with that.
But then just a week later,
we see this awful piece about Jordan and
enforced monogamy and it's just
nonsense.
It's just nonsense.
And you know,
I'm on tour with him right now and he
keeps explaining why that's,
of course he doesn't want anyone to be
forced to do anything and all that.
He's talking about marriage in effect.
Um,
and,
and Eric Weinstein,
our friend found two other references in
the history of the New York Times where
they talked about enforcement I'll give
me and they were both positive relative
to progressive ideals.
So it's like they flip everything on its
head.
But what do you think happened there?
I mean,
you're giving me a pretty good layout of
what's happened at the academic side,
but on the media side and those,
those gates,
what is going on?
I spent a lot of my life doing
journalism because I didn't have any,
uh,
inherited money.
And being an academic in Britain in the
19 eighties and nineties wasn't terribly
lucrative.
So I kept body and soul together,
even from my graduate years writing for
newspapers,
uh,
newspapers have had their own
transformation in the course of my adult
life.
A part of that sister economics,
as we all know,
the business model which essentially
revolved around advertising has been
annihilated by the combination of Google
and facebook and these institutions are
in some measure in desperation trying to
reinvent themselves for the Internet age
and everybody's in pursuit of clickbait.
Even the gray lady,
even the most illustrious of,
of newspapers.
And I think that's one explanation.
The other explanation is that an
institution like the New York Times has
its own university,
like character behaves a little bit like
university.
The most self important newspapers if
you go to them are rather like colleges.
And it's also true of the Financial
Times,
which is that like a kind of Cambridge
college that sort of ended up by mistake
in London.
And so they have some of the same
dynamics as,
as universities.
And I think that's especially true of
the New York Times.
Also true of the BBC incidentally.
So institutions like the times and the
BBC are think of themselves as being
liberal bastions,
but for them liberalism is truth.
It's the same problem at Harvard has,
if you,
if your motto is Veritas,
but you translate that into liberalism,
then by definition conservatives and
must be untruth and so I think there's a
tendency and it's there and in the New
York Times periodically to lash out
against anyone like Jordan Peterson who
dissents from liberal orthodoxy.
Remember,
part of what we're dealing here with is
a kind of quiz I religious phenomenon.
The dogmas of the left have become more
and more religious in their quality as
they have been unmerge from that
fundamental economic rationality which
was at the heart of Marxism when that
all went down in flames in 1989,
the left decamped to the realm of
culture and as it did that it
increasingly to on the form of a cult,
a good.
Let me illustrate what I mean.
Colts defined themselves partly by a
belief in a lot of things that are
slightly weird.
In order to be an account,
you have to have some weird beliefs and
one good example of a weird belief is
that sexuality is entirely constructed
socially and is not biologically rooted
and you can actually have any gender you
like and there are actually multiple
genders now that's absurd,
but to believe it has become a kind of
test of your orthodoxy.
Uh,
and,
and one sees this at meetings are in
academia in which people introduce
themselves by name and by their
preferred pronouns.
Now,
when this first happened to me,
my immediate reaction was introduced
myself and say that my preferred
pronouns were,
it restrain myself because I realized
that my sense of humor forged as it was
in Scotland in the 19 seventies is now
almost entirely politically incorrect.
And anything that I consider funny will
get me into trouble.
But that has gone on in the media too.
And the other thing that's happened is
that the polarization which
characterizes a network society is now
very visibly there in the realm of
newspapers and cable television.
One thing that we all got wrong about
the internet,
because we hadn't really thought much
about network science,
was that we just assumed that if
everybody was connected,
everything would be awesome and that was
the kind of mantra of Silicon Valley for
about 20 years,
but no network science tells you that if
you build a social network,
even quite a small one,
there will be something called homophily
because birds of a feather flock
together on bet you already.
That the intellectual dark web has two
clusters that are somewhat separate from
one another.
I sense it happening right now
immediately,
and that's what happened in the media.
So as society became more polarized
politically,
so to to the media,
I think that's an issue that is one of
the defining characteristics of our age.
The polarization or if you like self
segregation that we see online is
translated into almost every realm of
life.
Can there be any positives out of that,
out of that self selection,
into finding groups that you're more in
common with
that for at least for a certain period
of time.
There's some goodness there because you
can really sort of get into your ideas
enough to maybe leave the group then and
take those ideas out.
I think if you are in what you want to
call it,
the echo chamber or the filter bubble,
if you are in a cluster that cuts you
off from a contrary ideas,
you'll last.
Yeah.
What was fun about being in a network of
right leaning undergraduates in early 19
eighties?
Oxford was the.
We're in constant combat with the left
leaning Marxist that was still real.
Marxist is then and we weren't far from
cut off constantly engaging with them
and the soggies Social Democrats in in
the middle and that was what made it
interesting.
What I see happening in the networked
age is that people can retreat into a
realm of confirmation bias where they
here only things that are similar to the
things they liked yesterday and the
algorithms are the key here where you
are,
whether it's youtube or on facebook or
on twitter,
you are essentially going to be fed more
of what you already liked.
That's deeply intellectually unhealthy.
Just as a university cannot be a
university if everybody agrees about
first ideological principles because how
can you have critical thinking in that
environment?
So it's unhealthy for any intellectual
network to be Autarkic.
So the one thing the intellectual dark
web must not do is cut itself off from
other networks,
including the ones that hate us and when
we have to be in an argument and we have
to have our minds constantly open to the
possibility that we're wrong about some
things.
And that's what I see more or less
disappearing from public life.
I recognize this at one time,
uh,
when I was in,
in,
in mortal combat with Paul Krugman,
the economists turned journalist and,
and realize that recruitment could never
admit that he'd ever been wrong.
And then when it was obvious that he had
been because he hit his part of his
result,
Dettra was always being right about
everything.
Did you happen to see the day that the
article came out,
the original intellectual,
dark web article by Barry?
The day that that came out that Paul
Krugman tweeted it and he tweeted this
thing about how we're also oppressed,
you know,
just mocking everybody basically,
and then a bunch of us responded to him
and I of course retweeted it and invited
them on the show.
I said I'd be to discuss this,
you and it gets a couple thousand
retweets,
but of course,
no response.
Right?
And that you're right.
That's what we have to make sure we
don't become,
but I think there's a,
uh,
there's a human trait that would sort of
make you want to retreat because it's
exhausting having your motives attack.
Then your humanity attacked and lies and
smears and all the things that I don't
see anyone on this side doing.
I don't.
And,
and that's an example.
So it's an exhausting fight because
we're fighting two different battles.
Yes.
Supposedly the same trick
award at the moment in the sense that we
haven't recognized that in the culture
war.
The only thing that works is
reputational destruction.
I think we,
we are guaranteed sleepless nights.
Remember,
there's also the phenomenon of guilty
until proven innocent,
which is insidious and means that if the
reputational hit is bad enough,
there may be no,
uh,
there may be no recovery from that.
I was very struck by the speed with
which reputations were destroyed in the,
the me two movements,
uh,
most violent phase a and a
characteristic feature of the process
seemed to be the men were essentially
guilty until proven innocent and crimes
were conflated with a quite clearly
noncriminal behavior in ways that were
deeply troubling to my eyes.
The false accusation is,
of course the,
the ultimate nightmare of anybody in
this world at this time,
because if you're falsely accused,
uh,
well,
your reputation can be gone in 24 hours
and that,
that has an emt introduced into our
lives something that hasn't really
existed since medieval times.
Uh,
the feeling that we are at the mercy of
what wheel of fortune that can
arbitrarily turn against us and dashes
overturn us.
I think this makes the culture war,
uh,
a deeply troubling thing to be a part of
and most sensible normal people say,
God,
I want a quiet life.
Get me out of here and never involved me
in any of this.
Get me off twitter,
get me off facebook.
Never let my name appear in the New York
Times.
Never let me appear on a,
on a show like this because it's just
too dangerous.
Uh,
I only need to say one thing that can be
taken out of context and represented as
heresy or hate speech as heresy is now
called [inaudible].
That's what we now call heresy and I
will be subjected to potentially a weeks
of vilification and maybe worse,
maybe the vilification will actually
lead me to lose my job at.
People are right to be fearful of that.
One of the things that Eric,
who I mentioned before we had dinner
with and,
and just to illustrate this,
I'm sure you don't even want me to say
this,
but just to illustrate the level of what
we're talking about.
We had a private dinner in a home with
Eric and his wife and I and you and me
and my husband,
and we had.
There were security guards out outside,
so you're not.
You're not just saying this stuff like
this is.
This is real stuff,
but what Eric has said to me is that
it's exactly what you're saying,
that there's a bravery element here that
I don't even consider.
I don't consider myself.
I don't know what I'm just doing what I
think is right,
that that really is the truth,
but I want to ask you about that.
So.
So for you,
for ion,
it's not just academic.
Where do you think the bravery comes in
for you?
Because I can tell there is nothing that
I could possibly ask you here that you
wouldn't give me the clearest honest
answer and and that isn't always how it
is with everybody.
Obviously.
As an interviewer,
where do you think that comes from?
Uganda has always been one of my
greatest weaknesses.
I think
I was probably brought up in a rather
combative family in a rather competence
parts of the world.
I grew up in,
in Glasgow,
in the west of Scotland,
and
to a physician and a,
and a physics.
That's right.
My mother was a teacher.
My father was a doctor and they were the
first in their families to go to
university.
Uh,
my grandfathers had served in the world,
was a scots,
have a self image of themselves as being
a courageous.
The Scottish regiments were famous.
I wrote about this in my,
one of my earliest books,
the prisoner of war were famously the
sharp end of,
of the British military.
Uh,
we marched towards the sound of gunfire,
bagpipes playing.
That's the self image that a,
a small Scottish boy growing up in the
19 sixties and seventies was encouraged
to have.
I remember vividly the day that nine
slash 11 happened.
I was sitting in Oxford where I was then
teaching,
but planning I'd planned and was
intending to fly to New York a very
shortly to give a lecture on nine slash
12 at New York University.
Indeed,
I was booked into a hotel very close to
the World Trade Center and my response
when I saw the attacks was somewhat a
bloody minded.
My response was very shortly afterwards
to resign my posts at Oxford and go to
New York University,
and I taught there for two years in a,
I suppose a mood of defiance that the
attempt to terrorize would not terrorize
me.
When I met a on a nine more than nine
years ago now,
it never crossed my mind as I fell in
love with her,
which happened very fast,
that this implied some meaningful,
a threat to my person.
Even when the FBI came to tell me that
there had been a threat against me,
something that I'd seen them due to a
yarn on more than one occasion.
I never gave it a second thought because
obviously my calling different from my
grandfathers who were called to fight in
real wars.
My more,
much more manageable callings to is to
protect her.
But she's one of the great heroines of
our time.
Extraordinary courageous woman who's
been through a hell of a lot and who is
never shirked from saying what she
believes is wrong with modern Islam,
so it,
it is second nature to me to be there
with her in that,
in that fight,
in that war.
That's what it turns out to be.
My warm.
I always used to wonder as I was growing
up,
why is it that my generation isn't
really been called on to fight wars the
way my grandfather's generations were
called on,
and then it turned up.
Then my water turned up.
You briefly mentioned this earlier when
you were talking about ion and brandeis,
but can you explain this intersection of
Islamism and the left?
How,
why this has occurred.
This confuses a lot of people.
This idea of the oppression Olympics and
you know,
I've got plenty of theories on this that
we've knocked out,
but,
but what do you think it is that has
attracted something that is completely
totalitarian and control with another
thing that's so completely totally.
I mean,
I guess that's the answer right there,
but.
Well,
there are many unholy alliances in,
in history.
And,
uh,
no,
don't,
many people will gravely,
uh,
surprised when the Ribbentrop Molotov
pact was announced in the Soviet Union
and Nazi Germany,
you formed an alliance.
So we shouldn't be entirely surprised
when seemingly odd bedfellows jump into
bed in the case of the Islamists and the
left,
I think it's pretty clear to me that the
Islam,
this are the,
the leading partner and the leftists
have broadly the useful idiots because
the Islamists have a strategy.
It's bare and Muslim Brotherhood and
other documents for expanding their
network in the west.
And part of the strategy is the kind of
a partnership that they have formed on
campuses against,
uh,
against their foes.
One way in which this is that you use
the issue of Israel,
uh,
to forge the packs with the left.
So you get the left's longstanding
animosity towards Zionism,
uh,
and you essentially say,
well,
we entirely agree with you about that.
Let's,
let's have an event about how wicked
Israel is a.
and so that's the gateway drug into
accepting.
The next thing is well headscarves or
actually empowering for women.
Don't you think?
A and isn't actually Islamophobia to be
in any way critical of sharia law.
So you play the multiculturalists
cultural relativist card and you again
depict any critics of radical Islam as
it is in fact,
uh,
engaged in some kind of orientalist
project,
a or essentialist project to other
people always talk about othering in
academia,
uh,
Muslims and you blur the distinction
between Islam,
Islam,
Islam and Muslims as people.
So this has been going on for awhile and
the left as broadly fallen for it and
it,
to me,
it's just astonishing.
I remember looking at the list of
academics who had,
who had argued that they aren't,
should not receive an honorary degree at
Brandeis,
and it included professors of Queer
Studies,
a female professors of gender studies.
It's incredible.
You kind of feel like saying to these
people,
have you taken a look at what the Muslim
Brotherhood envisages have you read
works?
Do you realize that the project is the
permanent demotion of women to second
class status and potentially a capital
punishment for gays?
Is that something you are aware of?
And I can only conclude that they aren't
aware of it.
And have been very thoroughly duped as
useful.
Idiots usually are.
So is that basically because both of
these movements wind power,
so the useful idiot part of this is that
Islam is a really just using the left
who attain power and they're doing it
all in the name of diversity and all of
these things.
And eventually,
once that power is attained,
then for lack of a better expression,
I mean,
you basically decapitate them and then
you've got,
they did it for you.
They did the work for you.
Yes.
I mean,
I always used to joke with a on that,
uh,
when we lived in Cambridge,
it would be fun if all my enemies and
all her enemies came and protested
outside our house together because after
about 20 minutes and they'd fall on one
another and they would have the most
tremendous fight.
I do think that power is part of it,
but if one looks back at the history of
another intolerant to Talla Terry and
ideology of Marxism,
that there's a combination of power and
a,
a kind of idealism.
One must call it that in the square and
the tower.
I tell the story of how the Soviet
successfully penetrated the British
establishment by recruiting spies and
Cambridge and the people they recruited
had leanings to the left that were
inspired partly by revulsion at those
aspects of of British imperialism or
British society,
that word in many ways a legitimately
open to criticism.
There was an idealism there at the
beginning of guide Burgess's involvement
in Marxism,
sympathy with workers during the time of
the Great Depression,
but those were the useful idiots that
the Soviet cynically recruited to be
spies who,
whom they persuaded to betray their
countrymen in what was the single most
successful act of of Russian espionage,
of the mobile recruiting.
These highly educated people from an
credibly exclusive network,
the Cambridge Apostles and the related
network that led to Bloomsburg.
This was a brilliant strategy.
Something similar is going on here
because I think there are a great many
naive young people who are drawn to the
rhetoric of social justice.
I encountered them often.
People who say,
oh,
there should be limits on free speech
because I don't want such and such a
such and such as feelings to be hurt.
They're naive,
they have a very naive view,
somehow there can be a circumscribed
form of free speech and no in which
nobody's feelings get hurt.
That's not the pursuit of power.
That's just naive city and the people
who know how to explain that naive 30
are both people amongst the Islamists
and people amongst the leftists who are
pursuing power,
but you can never really get to power
without the useful idiots without the
naive idealists who think that they're
going to build utopia with your help.
Yeah,
and I don't have to tell you,
they're usually ends up in Dystopia,
right?
So that,
that's,
that's something that it's hard to
persuade people of y'all keep reflecting
on the curious revival of,
of Margaret Atwood's the handmaid's
tale,
which is always taken to be a vision of
what happens when right wing people,
uh,
take over America.
And to me,
the amazing thing that is almost never
observed is that something very like
this has happened.
Uh,
it happened in Iran after 1979 and it
happened after the Taliban came to power
in Afghanistan.
So we don't need to fantasize about
crazy evangelical fascists turning women
into baby machines.
This has already happened,
but it was done by Islam as it was done
by people pursuing an extreme version
of,
of Sharia.
And yet almost nobody who enthuses about
Margaret Atwood's book realizes that it
is actually really quite powerful
realization of what a theocratic Islam
this regime does to women.
All right,
so I want to shift gears a little bit
here and we can either.
I'm going to let you choose.
We can either go the historical root or
we can go to the president route.
What are you feeling first?
I do want to do both.
I think the key to apply to history,
which is what I've spent my whole life
doing,
is that you do both and you can't do one
without the other because no,
you could have no real insight about the
present without the past.
So why don't we talk about the president
and I'll try to show why to understand
that you need history.
All right,
very good.
So,
uh,
there are a couple of things that are
interesting that you've staked out
positions out over the past couple of
years.
Uh,
we briefly,
right before we sat down,
we talked about brexit for a second.
So you originally were for,
were against brexit.
Yeah.
Then you came around for it.
Now it seems to be in this odd limbo
that I think unfortunately most people
in America don't even understand what's,
what's going on.
I don't think most people in Britain,
I'm sure.
Um,
so when I was reading your position on
this,
at first I thought,
well,
wait a minute as a,
as a conservative and as someone that
wants some autonomy over his country,
I was somewhat surprised actually,
that you weren't for it originally.
So can you explain to your original
position and then how you changed on it?
The two reasons why I was on the side of
remain remain in the EU,
uh,
back in 2016.
One was pure personal loyalty to friends
up.
David Cameron was prime minister.
George Osborne was chancellor of the
Exchequer and they,
uh,
friends of mine and I,
I felt obliged as a friend to support
them when they decided to stick with the
EU or not to recommend brexit.
Did that friendship supersede what your
feelings were or was that because you
really trusted what they could get into?
Swung it.
Okay.
And I think the reason that I was
willing to,
to get on board with Romaine was that I
found the arguments of the brexiteers
deeply unconvincing.
I remember one night sitting down and
reading a lot of stuff by Daniel Hannan,
one of the advocates of,
uh,
of leaving.
And I remember thinking that this was
just intellectually completely a foot
class and unconvincing the,
the notion that Britain would be better
off economically outside the European
Union wouldn't have passed muster as a,
an undergraduate paper,
another undergraduate paper.
So I felt that the brexiteers case
failed intellectually because they were
claiming implausibly.
I thought that you could have a free
lunch,
that you could leave the European Union
and be better off.
And that just seems to me to be
intellectually completely deceitful.
I think it would have been harder for me
if they had said,
honestly,
this is going to cost quite a bit,
but it's worth it because if we leave
then we shall have the ability to
control our borders and we shall have a
autonomy at a time when Europe is
pursuing a federalists course.
But that wasn't the argument.
The argument was that not the argument
here,
Wednesday get the money.
This was the argument you had to get the
money that we give to the European Union
and we're going to be able to spend on
the national health service because we
will be in fact better off.
And that was a lie and I'm not good with
lies.
It was a clever line.
It worked politically.
And I give credit to Dominic Cummings
for crafting a message that was a pd
both to conservatives and to Labor
voters.
The Conservatives got immigration
control,
Labor voters got the national health
service,
gets the money.
So this is brilliant politically,
but it wasn't mendacious I think at
heart.
And so I,
I opposed the brexit when it happened.
Uh,
what struck me in the subsequent months
was that while I had been one,
I had been on the side that last,
there was a good reason why we lost and
the good reason was that we went around
saying how much it was going to cost and
I think we were right about that.
I think ultimately at least some of what
the Treasury said,
well will turn out to be true about the
cost,
but that wasn't what people cared about.
And when you went into pubs as I did in,
in,
in Wales and England and in Scotland,
there was a question to which you could
not give an honest answer without losing
the debate.
And I'll tell you what that question was
because I was asked it multiple times.
You'd make the case about the cost.
Nobody was interested in the cost.
They would say,
listen Neil,
about the one point 3 million Muslims,
the Germans have just let in to Germany
because that had just happened.
If the Germans give them German
passports,
can they come here?
And the only honest answer to that
question was yes.
So immigration was the issue.
And I think for a significant number of
people in England and Wales especially
was less so in Scotland where brexit was
defeated.
The realization was that Britain had
lost control of immigration.
The people had been promised net
migration in the tens of thousands in
the 19 nineties under the Blair
government,
and they'd ended up with net migration
and the hundreds of thousands,
they saw the chaos in Germany.
They saw the waves of migration coming
on in different Syria,
but from all over North Africa and uh,
and even so Asia.
And they said,
and I remember David Cameron using this
phrase,
get me out of here.
And that was,
that was the driving motivation for the
brexit vote.
And I think it was legitimate because I
think that Anglia Merkle had made a
catastrophic mistake and throwing open
the gates.
I think it will have consequences for
the future of Germany and of Europe.
And I do not blame British voters for
saying forget about the cost of brexit.
We really need to get out of this.
So I take the view by the end of 2016
that you had to,
you had to respect the fact that
ordinary people had cut through the crap
of the debate and it got to the heart of
the matter and the heart of the matter
wasn't the cost of Brexit,
which is what I had,
I think mistakenly focused on prior to
the referendum.
What was it like for you as a public
person and someone that writes about
this stuff and put your opinions out
there that have that realization?
I think it's very important if you write
regularly,
if you are what we call a public
intellectual,
a to be willing to admit that you've
been wrong.
I think you have to be prepared to say I
was wrong and I.
I think I was wrong in the sense that
what I wish I had done looking back was.
I wish I had said to David Cameron and
George Osborne in the spring of 2016
when it was clear that the Europeans
were going to make no meaningful
concession on the immigration issue.
When they basically sent an insulting
proposal about what could be done about
migration,
that was the moment I should have said
to cameron and Osborne,
forget it.
Yeah,
you should campaign for Brexit if that's
all they're going to offer you.
If they're so completely oblivious to
the very real concerns about
immigration,
then you should campaign for brexit
instead of which we stuck with it and
that was.
That was David Cameron's great mistake.
He should have said at that moment if
that's all you've got,
I'm going to recommend brexit to the
voters and it would have saved him too.
So.
So you think it was just,
it was just a bad negotiating play that
he just didn't use some leverage to say
we're going to have to walk away from
this.
There was,
there was a moment when he should have
walked away and I should have advised
them to walk away.
So yeah,
I think one has to recognize when
someone's made a mistake with such
consequences.
The second thing which is worth knowing
about this is that the people who then
inherited power after the fall of
Cameron and Osborne,
we're not the people who had campaigned
for and one on racks and it was people
who had been on the remain side.
Theresa may became prime minister.
Uh,
I always knew that would be a disaster.
I did not have high regard for her prior
to the referendum.
The Daily Mail essentially put her in
that position and also Boris Johnson,
Michael Gove and others because they
bungled the leadership contest.
So we then ended up with a terrible
combination which was a commitment to
Brexit,
but it's execution in the hands of
people who had been remainers.
And I think the result is the worst of
both worlds because right now we
essentially have the psychological
reality of brexit.
I think British public to a large extent
has accepted that we are leaving,
but the execution is a total mess by
invoking article 50 early on the UK in
essentially seated the,
the power and the divorce to the
European Union.
And the concessions have come one after
another.
Ever since then and we now find
ourselves in the odd predicament that I
think Theresa May is saying that brexit
means you ceased to be a voting member
of the European Union,
but you remain within the customs union
potentially even within the single
market and you accept all the rules and
regulations of the European Union.
You just don't have any power.
If that's the end game,
then it's a disaster so that the people
that are trying to stop this now,
they want to invoke some some pretty
crazy extreme stuff.
Right?
I mean there would be some really,
very rarely if ever used rules.
Am I right about this that would
actually allow this to allow the state
to occur.
Well,
listen,
I think there's going to,
without getting into all of them,
I knew that there is a level of
complexity in the discussions now in
London that is bewildering to most
ordinary procedure people when people
start talking about Max Faq and the
customs union complex.
Confusing,
right?
Because I discussed it with Douglas
Murray and he was even a little
confused,
so it's actually not confusing in the
sense that what is happening is that
Theresa May is trying to get Britain to
accept the realities of a belonging to
the European customs union,
which would preclude Britain having its
own trade policy,
uh,
with our leaving the European Union's
decision making body.
So essentially in that version,
brexit is just a,
you have the responsibilities,
you just don't have any power anymore,
which is definitely not what the British
public was told that it was getting in,
in brexit.
Uh,
the,
the bigger problem in my mind is not one
that,
that we've discussed.
And that is that all of this will end in
tears to the point at which Jeremy
Corbyn,
the most left wing leader of the Labour
party has ever had in its history,
becomes prime minister because Theresa
May is leading the country towards this
very unhappy compromise at some point.
The people who truly believe in Brexit,
Jacob Riis smog,
for example,
uh,
perhaps Michael Gove,
they may decide when we can't ultimately
accept this and the government,
they may fall.
But the problem is that if the
government falls,
then Jeremy Corbyn is prime minister.
Uh,
if the government doesn't fall and we go
all the way to the finishing line with
this Theresa May version of Brexit,
then I think the Conservatives will lose
the next election in 20,
22 and Jeremy Corbyn will be prime
minister.
So the worst are about brexit is in my
view that if it is bungled in this way,
it will open the door to a truly leftist
government and that will be far more
economically damaging than anything
brexit has done.
And that's the nightmare scenario for
me.
And probably socially damaging and
figures zillion other reasons deeply.
We should be extremely suspicious of
Corbyn and his people.
They are committed Marxists.
They've been on the wrong side of every
issue in my lifetime with a possible
exception of South African apartheid.
And I do not trust them with the keys to
10 Downing Street because I think that
their ultimate agenda is a truly
revolutionary one,
a,
and it poses a threat to the fundamental
liberties,
the traditions of the constitution.
It's a dangerous,
dangerous prospect.
And I'm much more worried about carbon
that,
about brexit.
I mean,
this is how I feel about what's
happening with our left in America to
that you guys are giving us basically
the
cursor to this.
I think one of the lessons of history
and now we can bring history in,
is that with populism,
you,
you get two flavors in a typical
backlash that would come after the
financial crisis.
Uh,
the political establishment discredited.
There's a backlash against inequality,
uh,
all of the things that typically follow
a financial crisis.
But there are two possibilities.
There's the populism of the left,
which is the tax,
the rich solution,
but the populism of the writers more
potent because it says that it's about
immigration.
It's about globalization,
it's about free trade.
And so broadly speaking,
there's a very good study that shows
this afro big financial crises,
the populace of the right.
Do better because they offer a more
plausible story,
but if they don't deliver when they
generally don't,
because quite hard to make immigration
control and terrorists pay quite hard
actually to make your constituents
better off with those policies,
then the pendulum has a tendency to
swing to the populism of the left and
that has happened in Britain really
quick because Corbyn became popular very
soon after brexit.
It's slower here,
but the fear must be that are.
If the trump experiment goes as wrong as
the vast majority of of intellectual to
expect it to.
The pendulum will swing to the left of
the Democratic Party.
And that scenario seems to me more and
more plausible are.
And I don't think that's a.
that's a not an appetizing then.
That's genuinely scary to me.
But I want to back up for one second
because the moment that you had that,
you said a few times happened in these
pubs when you would go there and people
would say this about one point 3 million
Muslims in,
in Germany.
How do you.
So,
okay,
so if you were listening to the
mainstream media,
they would say these people are all
racist.
That's what they would tell you.
They're,
they're racists and they're bigots.
I suspect that's not what you think of
these people,
although there probably was a certain
amount of people that are just racist
and don't like people have a different
color or a different culture.
How do you even have that conversation?
Because that's what so much of this is
about because you,
I'm sure we'd have a pint with these
people and you'd talk to them and
realize that they weren't racist.
They were actually just worried about
their future,
which is legit.
But if you can't have that discussion
because every time you open your mouth,
they tell you you're racist.
Well then we know what you end up with.
Look,
I would be a very strange
if I took a bigoted view on this subject
because I'm an immigrant.
I'm in fact,
it's about to become an American
citizen.
Uh,
in a matter of weeks.
My wife was a refugee who got from
Somalia originally to the Netherlands by
applying for asylum.
Uh,
and so we would be the last couple to
take a kind of a bigoted view on the
immigration issue because we're
immigrants.
When I had conversations on this subject
at the time of the brexit referendum,
I remember realizing that the opposition
to immigration was not plausibly a
racist because I remember somebody
making the point that he was as worried
about the people from Lithuania and
Poland coming to Britain as he was about
people from Syria and Iraq.
Uh,
and you probably know that people from
Poland and Lithuania are pretty wide.
So here's the thing,
what we all read to recognize is that if
immigration shoots up,
if it grows from,
in the case of Britain,
10,000
or $20,000
a year to 200,000
or 300,000
a year,
perfectly unprejudiced,
people will say,
that's too much.
This is going too fast.
And that I think was the dominant
argument.
Of course there are people who are
racists in any society.
But the striking thing about Britain is
actually that it's not a terribly racist
place.
Did you see many people protesting
against Prince Harry's decision to marry
an American of mixed mixed race?
I was there a couple of days before the
delivery.
Exactly.
Were
huge crowds.
This matches extraordinary popular with
ordinary people.
So I think it's hard to argue that
racism played any meaningful part.
Uh,
the,
the white supremacist element in Britain
is really,
is really very insignificant.
And actually one of the ways in which
the British like to define themselves is
as being tolerant,
uh,
memories of the war of not entirely
faded.
Even as the wartime generation gradually
disappears from the scene.
What was the war against apart?
It was a war against the ultimate racist
state.
What her Jeremy Corbyn the most in the
last three or four months.
The evidence that there are antisemitic
elements within his faction of the Labor
left that hurt him.
And it's important that that argument
being made because it has real truth to
it.
And I think ordinary people think that's
no good.
So I think this is not really about
racism.
It's not about bigotry.
It's about how rapidly should
immigration occur,
how large should flows be across
borders,
and the lesson of history is that if you
allow a real surge in immigration,
there will be a populous backlash
against us.
What happened in the United States in
the late 19th century,
the peak in the 18 eighties,
the foreign born percentage of the
population in the US was about 14
percent and gone up from relatively low
level to about 14 percent.
Same thing has happened in our time.
It was down I think below seven percent
in the mid 20th century,
in the period after World War Two
immigrants.
We're a relatively small proportion of
neat foreign born citizens were pretty
small portion of the US population.
And then from the 19 eighties onwards,
the proportion surged and the character
of the immigrants changed,
uh,
the places that they came from change.
And these changes are bound to elicit a
reaction.
It always happens and it's not enough
for people in the liberal elites who by
and large don't live in areas where
immigrants come to say,
what a terrible deplorable bunch of
chauvinists you are for not wanting a,
for not wanting more immigrants.
That's simply that simply historically
stupid.
Uh,
and the other thing that stupid about
this in the United States is a,
the people on the left who want to
legitimize illegal immigration.
Now,
I think for many people who were
attracted to trump,
the issue was the illegal quality of the
immigration.
The rule of law is a big deal in the
English speaking world,
and people don't like to hear anything
that simply says,
amnesty for lawbreakers,
or if you're a law abiding citizen and
you'll suddenly told,
well yet the law applies to you,
but there are these other people it's
not going to apply to.
Then your natural reaction is,
screw this.
That's why I thought one of his best
lines,
he doesn't use it as much anymore,
but during the campaign were either a
country or we're not.
I thought was a really effective line.
You either have laws or you don't.
I mean,
that in essence is the true.
So let's shift to trump a little bit
here.
Um,
I think that we're kind of in a similar
spot with him,
which is that it's better than the
alternative,
that that's certainly how I feel at this
point,
that all of the forces that we've spent
the last hour plus talking about would
be that much more emboldened against
free thought and all and free expression
and open inquiry and all the things that
we care about and historical fact and,
and everything else if he wasn't
president.
Right now,
I am deeply ambivalent about all of
this.
I think it's,
it's very,
very hard,
uh,
to say,
a good word about the personality of
Donald Trump.
I'm with you.
I,
it was a reason that I,
I found it impossible to support him in
2016.
I think one has to acknowledge that he
has a used inflammatory language,
uh,
on the issues are,
we've talked about immigration,
uh,
that he has a record of,
of,
of lying,
which is a,
even by the standards of American
presidents.
Pretty remarkable.
Uh,
and so the familiar list of things about
Donald trump that most of my friends
find objectionable is kind of hard for
me to,
to dismiss.
But I said I'm bivalent for a reason.
On the other hand,
number one,
what if he lost?
I said this to Sam Harris a few weeks
ago.
Let's run the counterfactual.
Let's just what historians should do.
Let's imagine an alternative history.
If Donald trump had lost the election by
let's say,
the same narrow margin that he wanted
it,
how would all those people who voted for
him have felt,
and how would they have behaved to my
mind?
The election of Donald trump is a
cathartic moment for those people.
So despised by the liberal elites that
they could refer to them as deplorables.
The people who voted for Donald trump
are not by and large are racists,
are not by and large,
uh,
anything like Donald Trump is
personally.
What attracted them to trump were two
things,
which as with the brexit campaign will
legitimate.
Number one,
they were attracted to trump's policy
positions on trade,
on immigration,
on Islam,
at and on our,
the somewhat a corrupt liberal elite
that had been running the country for
the previous eight years,
so I think they were attracted to
trump's policy positions,
but they were also attracted to his
cultural position and I think about half
of American populism is cultural.
What attracted the friends I have who
supported trump to trump was his
fundamental shift in language,
away from the politically correct
talking points of the political class,
Republicans and Democrats alike,
to a demotic normal way of speaking,
such as you would here in the typical
American bar,
more or less anywhere in the country
except Massachusetts,
Stanford,
California,
and the rest.
Now,
I,
I remember thinking on the eve of the
election,
if you line up all the people who are
going to vote for her and you line up
all the people who are going to vote for
him,
which line would you rather be in?
Remember at that point,
I'm not a citizen.
I don't know,
and I thought,
that's easy.
I'm with the people who are so pissed
with the political establishment that
they're ready to take a chance on this
guy because they see no other way to
shake things up.
The way my friend Jerry Blake put it to
me,
ex marine corps,
Xn ypd never went to college,
helps take care of my wife.
Security.
Jerry said to me early 2016 two things
that stuck in my mind.
First he told me trump was gonna win,
but then he said the two reasons why he
supported trump.
Number One,
he tells it like it is.
Number two,
he's going to shake things up by.
He tells it like it is.
Jared did not mean he is always
truthful.
What he meant was he talks like me by
shaking things up.
Jerry meant we have to do something
because this system as it stands is not
in my interests.
It's not in my interests economically
because it seems to favor China over the
United States.
Mexicans over a native born Americans
the rich one percent over me,
the median household,
but he's also.
It's also about this cultural reaction
against the multiculturalism that has
become the orthodoxy of the liberal
left.
So for all my reservations about trump,
I completely got why people voted for
him.
And I think their reaction had he lost,
we'd have been toxic.
I don't think they would have accepted
the legitimacy of the result.
I think they would have bought the
story,
trump would have told them that the
election being rigged,
and I think we would have had a poisoned
body politic from day one of the Clinton
presidency if it all ends.
Oddly though we're having that right
now,
just in the reverse,
right?
It would have been worse,
but we're having a left that's not
accepting the legitimacy of the
election.
And I think it would have been worse.
Yeah,
I think it would have been worse.
Uh,
and I think,
and this is another part of the story
that for Jerry and his and his many,
many fellow Americans who voted trump,
this has always been a gamble and
they've always had a sense that it could
go wrong.
You know,
when you shake things up sometimes they
break.
And I,
I sense that if it all ends in fiasco,
which I guess that the vast majority of
public intellectuals expect,
and some combination of Watergate and
other scandals,
I think Jerry and his and his fellow
American trump supporters will say,
well,
we gave it a try.
Give it a try.
And I,
I think that's,
that's one possible scenario.
The other reason that I am ambivalent
about trump is that for all his flaws,
in some ways he's doing a better job on
foreign policy than his predecessor did
a because trump has this superpower that
most intellectuals can understand.
He has an unerring instinct for the
weakness of the counterparty that it's a
kind of almost animal instinct.
But some are Donald Trump can tell when
the other side is weak.
You could see it in Jeb Bush,
you could see it in Marco.
Rubio could see it in Hillary Clinton,
and now I think he sees it in the
Europeans.
He sees in Angola Merkel,
you don't pay enough for your defense.
What if I walk out on NATO?
Yeah.
Well,
the season Kim Jong UN and he sees it in
Xi Jinping.
He sees it in the,
uh,
in the supreme leader in Neuron.
So my ambivalence is partly my sympathy
for trump supporters,
my fundamental sense of why they voted
for him.
But it's also that in some ways this
disruption has its plus side in the way
that it's repositioning the United
States.
I mean,
I,
to me,
it's given oxygen to everything that
we've talked about here.
And that doesn't,
that doesn't discount all of the
legitimate concerns that you look.
The big concern for me as I mentioned
before,
is that the pendulum swings the other
way.
If this all ends in tears,
all of those who defended it,
even if they defended it,
halfhearted delight me,
will be discredited.
And the damage will be irreparable,
uh,
for conservatives and populists alike.
The left we empowered and they will
spend the rest of our lives telling us
that we were apologists for the worst
president.
And that's,
that's not a scenario that you can
discount likely for a time.
I think it was exhilarating are freely
admit that for me,
one of the most satisfying aspects of
trump's victory was that all the people
I most dislike in this contract,
we're in a state of shock for weeks and
I remember things that are.
You know,
it can't be all bad if the people.
I really can't stand her in this state,
but you have to.
I think with history and mind,
be conscious of the dangers of the fact
that this could end so badly that it
does irreparable damage and and the
worst damage of all will be if it
propels the left of the Democratic Party
into power and that,
that you can't reload.
You can't really do that.
The worst thing about studying history
is that it makes you aware of under
terministic that historical processes
that there is always more than one
future.
Where's the future of trial as the
future of tragedy and there's this kind
of other future in the middle,
which is a little bit of both and that's
really one of the historical moment is
bad for restful sleep on wakes up in the
morning and I'm sure you have the same
feeling wondering what alert will be on
your phone and what message will be on
your phone.
Will the alert say was broken out,
will the alert say a palace coup and
will the message say,
uh,
your reputation has just been a been
destroyed by some accusation or other.
So one wakes up in a state of anxiety in
the United States of 2018.
And that is a reality for that I think
is inherent in both the culture war that
we've spoken about and the trump
presidency,
which is in some measure a backlash
against that.
That culture war.
We're going to leave it at that,
but I am going to demand that you come
back.
I don't think I've ever demanded that.
I guess come back,
I've been asked,
but I'm legitimately demanding that you
come back because next time I want to
do,
I want to just do all history and,
and even even barely jump in.
I want them to meet with the British
empire stuff and Churchill and.
Okay,
I'm demanding it.
Will you accept my demand except.
All right.
It took a long time to get you here but,
but considering we're both two guys just
off planes today and you're a,
you're like 87 hours out of whack and
jet lag and all the things we said will
be taken out of context on twitter.
Well,
I sincerely hope everything because
that's how you know,
the whole thing goes.
This has truly,
truly been an absolute pleasure and
thank you for doing this and send my
best.
Of course.
Diane.
Sure will.
And uh,
for more Neil,
you can follow him on twitter,
although you don't fight with people
that much on twitter,
which means,
which means you have strong moral
character.
I decided the jungle warfare was not the
way to go.
He's a wise man and it's at an F E R G U
S.